[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey everyone welcome back to potato mode
where we take the most beautiful games
we know and turn them into mush
my name is Joey I'm joined once again by
Rob handler thank you so much for having
me again and for today we have a game
that was mentioned quite a bit in the
comments so thank you all that commented
and reminded us that today is Star Wars
day may the fourth so what better way to
celebrate today then to play Star Wars
Battlefront - makes sense to me it
really does because also it's you know
it's the best-looking Star Wars game
right safe to say nighttime hello yeah
yeah so in case you haven't seen the
show before I'll do just real quick what
we do is we take really great looking
games like you're seeing right here and
we tried to you know dial it back to the
lowest possible setting that we can make
it and then we'll try to go even further
than that
see I think out of all the games that
we've played so far on potato mode this
is probably the best-looking
arguably I would I would argue that I
think so just like this game has
everything going for in terms of visuals
like the lighting is really great like
the effects right here mm-hmm all the
textures are really really crisp and it
is such a good-looking game absolutely
alright I think now is about a good time
for us to dig into the settings here oh
my god okay after saying after the
murder of a few stormtroopers of course
okay so I'm gonna go pause it right here
and I'm gonna take a look at the video
options that they have there's quite a
bit here you got you know the basics of
textures lighting shadows of eggs and
all that we're just gonna go straight up
get everything on low alright and we're
back in business
damn really a lot of pop a lot of pop in
like the level of detail scaling is a
little bit low well the one thing that
the game has is it allows you to control
the resolution scaling like some of the
other games that we've shown but this
game allows you to go pretty far with it
and lo ho there you got start seeing the
edges here yeah yeah yeah mm-hmm
at what point will this become a
hindrance to your play okay I mean right
now it's fine I'm still good it's so
good so good it's fine it's like when I
like wake up in the morning I'm trying
to get out of bed here's five percent
okay now just follow it follow the
damage indicators yeah that's the same
definitely having a hard time
identifying people what's the lows we
can go let's go one percent well you
have 940 cues remaining damn United
States rescind oh you sure I'm positive
alright so we've seen a little bit of
the arcade mode and we brought the
resolution scaling down but I went ahead
and changed some things in the Nvidia
profile inspector I'm sure if you've
seen the show before you know me pretty
familiar with that but what it does is
basically you know just removes a lot of
the textures and we're gonna go back
into the campaign this time that's
awesome this looks kind of cool really I
I think so you know I think we're
getting to a point where we just kind of
regard graphics like this as normal now
like yeah I feel like I'm almost there
there's a lack of texture but like color
and lighting is there and like yeah like
that like the particles of fire and yeah
all that stuff for embers honestly this
is kind of making me hungry excuse me
okay I know it is late in the day but I
feel like I can eat some of this like I
feel like I'm in like a a blended sundae
but like a sundae that's a little late
to the party like I said it's it's had
some melting melting a little bit but
that's just enough for you can actually
scoop it out yeah it's not gross it's
just like aa simple
dude I'll finish that for you can we
take a look at their faces really quick
sure okay can we stop just beer just
kind of spilling over his lip there
there it is there it is oh now he looks
there it is oh now he looks good wow
that's so cool just candy corn just
flying everywhere it's exactly right I'm
telling you dude this is this is the the
tastiest potato mode yet getting a lot
of dessert dessert yeah yeah oh yeah
screaming going on probably cuz people
are getting hit by gigantic pieces of
candy corn okay so we've seen the game
basically looking at it's worse right
now but I feel like we can we can have
some sort of in between and the way that
I thought we could go about that is
using this programmer here called the
cinematic tools and what this allows us
to do is basically give us free control
over the camera like we can move it
wherever we want essentially we'll be
able to make our own Star Wars movie
that's that's the dream at least so we
can we can position the camera basically
anywhere we want we could have it behind
her we can have a swinging front nice we
can also explore the map a little bit
more in detail we can get a really close
[Laughter]
[Music]
the glory of this is that you can move
the camera and play at the same time so
if you oh this is so awesome dude look
I'm controlling the camera on the
controller yeah and so I'm a keyboard
trying to play keep it straight here
cool let's go over there well put the
camera at me I don't know where I am
wow this game looks oh sorry clearly
right here because you're the one who's
not shooting or engaging oh all right
I'll help you out oh yeah that's the
other thing you can crash if we're gonna
make our own Star Wars movie like short
film
the Emperor's a good one to kick things
off okay so we're gonna be the em yeah
start with the upper oh I'd love to see
what chrome looks like we needs a little
polish I think in in this episode he had
to go to other people he's trying to
remember where it was in this building
dad he's the bathroom I always friggin
get I have to bring me Lord hello hello
okay so that's the story right he didn't
actually explode when being thrown down
the shaft he just like fell down and now
everyone's evacuating he's like what
what did I miss
nightmare he's like this is how he
really died this is how the Emperor
really died Shh you pee in one of those
right no one's using them let's do it no
no son boy it was evacuating man I fell
down on my hand earlier look how look
how it moves I hurt my wrist by the man
okay so he have textures reduce even
further on this did a little fiddling
with a profile inspector but and this
actually looks pretty badass launch
[Music]
holy Sh banner looks way worse guys also
look at them they look like army men
I feel like battlefront really doesn't
want us doing this
obi-wan never told you what happened
little father he told me enough
he told me you know I
[Music]
not true
not impossible shaky feeders who know
would be true
[Music]
come with me it is the only way
[Music]
real quick can we just take a look at
how chewy oh yes oh my god his hair was
a lie he's a hologram show me show me
the Magnificent Chewbacca Oh does that
image you see that image of a circle a
circulating of like Chewbacca shaved no
I want to see it's horrifying
[Laughter]
once again thank you guys so much for
watching if you have a game that you'd
like to see turned into mush kind of
like this bleep make sure leave in
comments below or hit us up on Twitter
be glad to take your suggestions and so
we will see you next Friday with another
episode what happened to you I was gonna
be pissed
if he ever finds out